The extent of
damage is
being increasingly is becoming
rather increasingly clear in Haiti
after a weekend of torrential downpours
and widespread flooding.
At least 42
people are dead,
dozens more injured
and thousands of homes destroyed.
Dramatic scenes like this
are taking place across the country.
And as residents try to outrun
the rising waters,
often
with little more than the clothes
on their backs.
And now we're learning
at least four people were killed
and 36 others injured.
Following a 4.9 earthquake
that struck Haiti earlier today.
The Caribbean island nation
is no stranger to hardship.
It's already struggling
with devastating
gang violence and political instability
while teetering on
the brink of economic collapse.
The U.N.
says even before this weekend's rain,
nearly half of Haiti's
population was in need
of humanitarian assistance.
Gary Pierre is the founder and editor
of The Haitian Times.
He joins us live now.
So, Gary,
thank you so much for being with us.
I wish we could talk about Haiti
in a much more positive context.
But here's the thing
just in terms of the situation
on the ground.
Gangs approximately control
about 80% of Port au Prince.
Obviously, you have vigilante
vigilantes that have sort of
now gone up against the gangs
and are attacking the gangs.
And essentially
taking the law into their own hands.
You also have flooding in various parts
of the country.
On top of that, an earthquake
that struck this morning.
How is Haiti
coping with these Back-To-Back
humanitarian disasters?
Thanks for having me, Zain.
And I must say,
my heart goes out to my fellow
Haitians in Haiti.
Who have been suffering so much.
But, you know,
this is a result of chronic bad
governance
that that's been decades in the making.
And we've seen the results.
Right now,
there is no functioning government for
for what it's worth.
People are left on their own to survive,
to defend for themselves.
The state,
the police can no longer provide that.
And on top of that,
we have these natural disasters.
Well, we know that Haiti's
and the Caribbean,
when it comes to major in July or August,
these are hurricane seasons, months.
And so
there's very little that the governments
pass and
have done to mitigate the disasters
once they come.
And so we need
a governance restore in Haiti
and so that the state can provide
the people with the help when
they need it.
So what are you hearing in
terms of what's happening in the ground?
I mean, obviously,
this these particular floods
have largely spared Port-Au-Prince.
Not entirely, but largely.
But there are still thousands of people.
13,000 people displaced
as a result of these floods.
What are you hearing from
the ground in terms of
what is the greatest need at this point?
Food, drinking water, I imagine shelter,
especially for those people
who no longer have a place to live.
The biggest need is shelter right now,
because you have to remember
that on top of these displaced people,
there were already displaced
people fleeing gang violence.
In the country
as and the city, as you mentioned.
And so right
now, people need water and shelter.
And we have reporters on the ground
working, reporting as we speak
on the conditions and what the needs are.
So in terms of
humanitarian groups and aid agencies,
what are they up against?
Because, yes, on the one
hand, you're navigating
humanitarian crises
just in terms of the flooding,
which a lot of these aid
agencies are used to.
But the environment is
particularly unique.
You've got gangs
controlling several parts of Port
au Prince.
And then on top of that,
you have
these vigilantes
who, as I mentioned,
have taken the law into their own hands
and who are now
attacking and murdering suspected.
This is key suspected gang members.
They don't even know
whether they're gang members for sure.
But if they suspect
they're a gang member,
they could end up dead
at the hands of these vigilante groups.
So what are the unique challenges
for aid agencies
operating in this kind of environment?
Well,
first of all,
many of these aid organizations
stop their work in Haiti,
most notably Doctors Without Borders,
because the situation
been so dangerous for them,
because they were operating
and gang controlled territory.
And other aid organizations
left for the most part
or have had their work
curtailed significantly.
So right now, it's unclear
what the government
is doing to alleviate the problem because
the biggest.
The other challenges, the gangs situation
because while you
you do have the vigilante
the back alley movement
that's also dangerous because it could
you know, go into lawlessness
the likes we haven't seen in Haiti
where
suspected people
use that movement to settle scores.
And then you have
another mess in our hands.
And so I think
the police need to regain control.
And also now to help facilitate
the humanitarian aid
that's desperately needed right now
with this earthquake
in the south
and the rain across the country.
I mean, I remember
seeing images of
of police officers
protesting in the streets
because they just
didn't know what to do
in terms of controlling these gangs.
Acting Prime Minister Ariel Sharon,
we did make an urgent plea
to the international community.
He wanted outside
international intervention,
possibly led by Canada
or the United States or the U.N.
to come and assist in terms
of containing
the gang violence in the country
where are we on that?
Because a lot of these countries
were reluctant to lead any such group.
Where does.
Where are we on that
and where does that leave Haiti?
Well, where we are, there is
CARICOM is trying to broker some kind of
movement, a deal
with the army and the opposition.
The primary opposition group
is the Montana Accord.
And so,
you know,
CARICOM is not equipped
to deal with Haiti
and the international community.
The U.N.
has had a shaky
past, and its interventions in the U.S.
right now
is just is not interested
and going back to Haiti.
And so while
the international community
trying to figure out how to help,
I think what needs what they can do
concretely is to help
the police regain control.
Right now, the police department in Haiti
is under arms embargo
while arms are flowing
into the gangs hands.
And so this is unfair.
And they need material.
They need all kinds of weapons
to fight these gangs
so that the country can have a chance
to stabilize itself
and get back on the way
to functioning democracy,
which, you know, is
and there is no elected official
in Haiti.
So right now,
Haiti's a democracy in name only.
It is not a practicing
or functioning democracy.
And a lot of people have issues
with the acting prime minister,
Oriol Honoré,
I wish we had time to talk about that
a little bit longer,
but I am out of time.
Gary,
thank you so much for being with us.